[Musik]
MURAT: Dam-da-dam-daaa! Dam-da-dam-daaa!
Oh, die Wurst! Sally!
Wasser! Sally!
SALLY: Murat!
MURAT: Feuer! Sally!
Murats 5 Minuten!
SALLY: Murat, ernschthaft?!
[Trommelwirbel]
Herzlich willkommen zu Murats 5 Minuten.
Heute bin ich alleine, und zwar in einer völlig fremden Küche,
und zwar in unserer privaten Küche,
weil in der Drehküche dort drüben –
da ist gerade die Sally dran an ihrem neuen Kochbuch.
Güni ist im Urlaub. Auf dem Bau ist die Hölle los.
Normalerweise wäre ich heute auch auf dem Bau,
aber wir drehen immer Videos vor,
sodass die Sally immer so ein bisschen einen Slot hat,
wo sie kreativ sein kann,
wo sie andere Projekte machen kann wie jetzt das Kochbuch –
komme ich mal rein als Sidekick und mach meine „Murats 5 Minuten“,
und heute aus unserer privaten Küche.
Vielleicht hat es jemand von euch schon einmal gesehen.
Ich glaube, Sally hat einmal hier etwas gemacht.
Wie gesagt, das ist die private Küche. Hier kochen wir privat.
Eigentlich kochen wir auch da hinten, eigentlich kochen wir überall.
Bei uns gibt’s kein Privat und kein Geschäftlich mehr.
Irgendwie geht alles ineinander hinein.
Und, wie gesagt, heute mache ich „Murats 5 Minuten“-Rezept.
Es gibt Chicken Florentine Pasta –
hört sich cool an, sind eigentlich nur…
Auf Deutsch gesagt: Hähnchen mit Nudeln.
Genau, ist halt nicht so cool.
My name is Jamie Oliver, I’m from Great Britain.
Bin ich natürlich nicht. Ich bin der Murat aus Waghäusel.
Und deswegen mache ich euch einmal dieses Rezept.
Bevor wir mit dem Rezept anfangen,
machen wir als allererstes Folgendes:
Wir tun den Backofen auf 80°C vorheizen.
Einfach Ober-/Unterhitze, zack! 80°C und starten.
[Musik]
Also, die Zutaten sind Folgende:
200 g Champignons, die braunen, 1 Bund Frühlingszwiebeln,
500 g Hähnchenbrust, 1 TL Salz, 1/4 TL Pfeffer, je nach Geschmack,
1 TL Paprika Edelsüß,
Linguine oder Bavette, das könnt ihr machen, wie ihr möchtet,
und 2 EL Olivenöl zum Anbraten.
Für die Sauce benötigen wir 2 EL Butter, 3 EL Mehl,
2 Knoblauchzehen, 150 g Gemüsebrühe, 150 g Milch,
1 TL Salz, Pfeffer und 120 g Blattspinat.
Ihr seht, es ist ein ganz einfaches Rezept. Sind nur 10 Zutaten.
Normalerweise hat man die auch daheim.
Die Zutaten können ein bisschen variieren.
Oftmals sind bei Champignons z. B. 250 g pro Packung.
Egal, dann nimmst du halt 50 g mehr.
Und bei den Frühlingszwiebeln je nach dem Geschmack.
Also Rezepte sind ja nicht in Stein gemeißelt.
Je nachdem, was ihr gerne mehr mögt, macht ein bisschen mehr rein.
Kein Thema.
Da Güni heute nicht da ist,
versuche ich mal die 5 Minuten hinzubekommen.
Fangen wir gleich an. Nehmen wir das Olivenöl,
tun wir die Pfanne hochheizen.
2 EL, da kann’s ein bisschen mehr sein.
Meiner Meinung nach kann’s nie genug Olivenöl sein.
So. Vielleicht wundert ihr euch, warum ich mit Olivenöl anbrate.
Das ist bei unserem Olivenöl möglich. Das ist aus der Frühernte.
Jetzt nehme ich das Fleisch. Das ist Hühnchen.
Ich mag Hühnchen mehr als Pute.
Pute ist etwas dunkler. Meistens ist Pute überzüchtet.
Deswegen nehme ich eher Hähnchenfleisch.
Ich mag auch vielmehr das Faserige.
Und deswegen greife ich gern zu Pute.
So, jetzt tu ich das würzen.
Fangen wir gleich an mit dem Würzen.
So. Bisschen Salz, bisschen Pfeffer.
Das macht ihr je nach Geschmack.
Wenn ihr andere Gewürze mögt, könnt ihr auch andere Sachen reinmachen.
So. Und was auch nicht fehlen darf: ein bisschen Paprika.
[Musik]
So. Das Hähnchen jetzt bei mittlerer Hitze anbraten.
Bei Hähnchen ist ganz, ganz wichtig, dass Hähnchen durch ist.
Das ist nicht so beim Rindfleisch.
Wenn es nicht ganz durch ist beim Rindfleisch –
das mögen sehr, sehr viele.
Hähnchen, ganz, ganz wichtig, durch,
aber nicht so durch, dass es richtig trocken ist.
Das mag ich auch nicht.
Wenn Hähnchen richtig hart und trocken geworden ist,
mag ich es absolut nicht.
Das heißt, wirklich nur 5 Minuten kurz auf mittlerer Hitze anbraten,
dass es außen goldgelb ist.
[Musik und Bratgeräusche]
So. Während das Fleisch anbrät,
nehme ich schon einmal die Frühlingszwiebeln
und tu die schon einmal schneiden.
[Doing]
Ich finde den Mülleimer nicht. Wo ist der? Ah, hier! Genau.
In meiner eigenen Wohnung finde ich den Mülleimer nicht. [Lacht]
[Musik]
Ich mag’s ein bisschen bissfester.
Deswegen mache ich es nicht so fein.
Und natürlich die Champignons.
Bei den Champignons ist ganz, ganz wichtig:
Viele machen den Fehler, die tun die Champignons wirklich waschen.
Dann ziehen die richtig Wasser auf
und dann wird eure Sauce nachher zu wässrig.
Deswegen Champignons bitte nur mit dem Tuch abputzen. So.
Die habe ich schon abgeputzt.
Und die könnt ihr jetzt mit dem… Ich mag den Stiel genauso.
Manche werfen den Stiel sogar weg.
Und einfach vierteln.
[Musik]
So. Während das Fleisch jetzt anbrät,
haben wir das Gemüse geschnitten.
Und, wie gesagt, bei den Nudeln:
Normalerweise benutzt man hier Linguine. Ich benutze Bavette.
Der Unterschied ist eigentlich nur die Form,
und nicht krass, sondern nur ein bisschen.
Und ich liebe Barilla.
Wirklich, also das ist jetzt keine Produktplatzierung.
Ich liebe diese Nudeln einfach.
Ich weiß, dass manche von euch Cecco lieben.
Manche lieben Gaggli Nüdeli aus der Schweiz.
Manche lieben Zabler Hochzeitsnudeln.
Ich mag Barilla über alles. Die Nudeln sind wirklich klasse.
Und da gibt’s eine ganz, ganz krasse Geschichte eigentlich.
Das sage ich eigentlich jedes Mal,
wenn ich Barilla nutze, dass ich Barilla liebe.
Und zwar gibt es eine krasse Geschichte.
2013 gab’s ein Radiointerview, und zwar mit dem Inhaber.
Ich weiß nicht. Ich glaube, der war damals 60 oder 65 Jahre alt.
Und zwar Guido Barilla. Es ist ein riesen Familienunternehmen.
Ich glaube, die machen über 4 Mrd. Umsatz
und liefern in alle Länder dieser Welt.
Und da gab’s ein Radiointerview. Da haben sie gefragt:
Barilla macht immer Werbung mit der Familie.
Das heißt, die Mutter kocht, Papa ist da, die Kinder sind da.
Und mein Handy klingelt…
Barilla liefert in die ganze Welt.
Und die machen ja Werbung oftmals mit der Familie.
Das heißt, die Mama kocht, Papa kocht, die Kinder laufen rein,
Oma und Opa sind da. Also sehr, sehr traditionelle Familienbilder.
Und da hat mal ein Radiomoderator Guido Barilla gefragt:
„Sag mal, in deiner Werbung –
Warum gibt’s da nicht 2 Frauen als Pärchen oder 2 Männer als Pärchen?“
Und dann hat der Guido Barilla gesagt:
„Ich habe Respekt vor diesen Menschen, aber das ist nichts für mich
Die sollen andere Nudeln kaufen.“
Das gab einen riesen Shitstorm in der LGBT-Bewegung.
Prominente haben dann Barilla boykottiert.
Die Harvard Universität hat gesagt,
bei uns in der Kantine gibt’s keine Barilla Nudeln mehr.
Gab wirklich einen riesen Shitstorm.
Es ist oftmals so im Leben, dass es manchmal ältere Menschen gibt,
die noch in einer anderen Zeit leben.
Ich bin davon nicht ausgeschlossen, muss man ehrlich sagen,
weil meine Eltern, meine Mama versteht auch noch alles nicht,
was heute momentan in der neuen Zeit passiert, will sie auch gar nicht.
Hab ich privat auch schon erlebt.
Ich habe mal eine Ausbildungsstelle angefangen
und dann war der Senior Chef und der Junior Chef da.
Und der Senior Chef sagte dann:
„Herr Özcan, aber nicht dass Sie hier Ihr Gebetsteppich ausbreiten!
Das dürfen Sie bei uns nicht machen.“
Und da hat der Junior Chef sofort eingelenkt:
„Papa, warum sagst du sowas? Sowas macht man nicht!“
Und so war es auch bei Barilla. Und zwar gab’s den Geschäftsführer,
der hat sich dieses Interview angehört und hat gesagt:
„Ach du Sch***e. Das hat der jetzt nicht gesagt, oder?“
Und das war ein riesen Shitstorm,
hat der Firma natürlich sehr, sehr viel Geld gekostet,
muss man ganz ehrlich sagen.
Aber seit diesem Tag,
seit 2013 hat Barilla extrem viel in diese Richtung gemacht:
Gleichstellungsbeauftragte eingestellt,
viel für diese Bewegung gemacht.
Und inzwischen gehören sie zu den Top-Unternehmen,
was Gleichstellung von Homosexuellen betrifft.
Und das ist echt der Wahnsinn, was die für ein Turnaround gemacht haben.
Auch traditionell ist Barilla immer blau.
Die haben die rosa Verpackung gemacht,
haben auch die Werbung geändert,
es sind auch gleichgeschlechtliche Paare zu sehen.
Eine richtig krasse Geschichte. Wollte ich euch nur mal erzählen,
weil ich das mal unter einem Video geschrieben habe:
„Das sind homophobe Nudeln.“
Die Nudeln sind nicht homophob.
Die Nudeln sind einfach aus Hartweizengrieß.
Ich mag diese Nudeln.
Und wie gesagt, dieses Unternehmen hat einen riesen Turnaround gemacht.
Sie sind nicht homophob. Ganz, ganz wichtig zu sagen.
Aber, wie gesagt, nur eine kleine Geschichte.
Mein Fleisch ist jetzt goldgelb angebraten.
Jetzt macht ihr Folgendes:
Wenn ihr es mal 5 Minuten von beiden Seiten angebraten habt,
dann macht ihr kurz nochmal den Deckel drauf
und lasst es nochmal 5 Minuten garen,
denn, ich habe es euch schon vorher gesagt,
wichtig bei Hähnchen ist, dass es wirklich gut durch ist
und nicht noch roh innen. 5 Minuten kurz anbraten lassen
und danach tun wir es in diese Schüssel rein
und dann in den vorgeheizten Backofen.
[Musik und Uhr]
Jetzt müsste es durch sein.
Jetzt tun wir es grad in die Emaille Schüssel rein, das Fleisch.
Wir haben ja vorher den Backofen vorgeheizt bei 80°C.
Jetzt tun wir es noch in den Backofen, dass es schön warm bleibt.
[Musik]
So. Und in die gleiche Pfanne tun wir jetzt das Gemüse anbraten,
und zwar wirklich nur 2 Minuten.
Und jetzt wirklich nur 2 Minuten anbraten, dass es richtig zusammenfällt.
So. Einfach wirklich nur 2 Minuten kurz anbraten.
Nicht so, dass es ganz zusammenfällt,
sondern wirklich dass es noch ein bisschen bissfest ist.
Ich mag das einfach.
Wenn ihr natürlich schlechte Zähne habt,
könnt ihr es auch durchmanschen. Könnt ihr auch machen.
Aber ich mag’s, wenn es noch richtig bissfest ist.
[Musik]
So. Jetzt holen wir das Fleisch raus.
Jetzt tun wir die Nudeln grad dazu.
Tschuldigung, das Gemüse, nicht die Nudeln.
Hab schon die Nudeln im Kopf.
Ich koche das auch voll gern in der Gusseisenpfanne,
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Ist einfach ein cooleres Geschmackserlebnis.
Und das Tolle an der ganzen Geschichte ist,
man kann alles in einer Pfanne machen.
So sieht’s jetzt aus – und rein in den Backofen wieder.
Jetzt haben wir alles in die Pfanne, eh, in den Backofen gemacht.
Jetzt nehmen wir die Butter
lassen sie schmelzen.
Dann nehmen wir die Knoblauchzehen.
Die sind noch nicht geschält,
aber wenn ihr so eine Knoblauchpresse habt,
braucht ihr sie nicht zu schälen.
So, einfach hier rein, ungeschält. Und einfach draufdrücken.
Jawoll! So, jetzt machen wir einen dirty Jamie Oliver Move.
Perfekt!
Ich glaube, es gibt keinen besseren Geruch
als Butter mit Knoblauch in einer Pfanne anzubraten.
Dann machen wir Folgendes:
Wir nehmen hier 150 ml Gemüsebrühe.
Da hat meine Frau schon ein Rezept für Gemüsebrühe selber gemacht.
Hier unten in der Infobox kommt ihr zum Rezept.
Auch ein ganz, ganz cooles Video.
Wenn ihr keine Gemüsebrühe habt,
könnt ihr auch eine Hühnerbrühe nehmen.
Jetzt tun wir das langsam reinschütten.
Und richtig schön köcheln lassen.
So. Dann geben wir noch die Milch dazu.
Und zuletzt noch das Mehl.
Das ist eigentlich so ähnlich wie eine Béchamelsauce.
Und jetzt noch schön langsam…
So, und jetzt einfach so ein bisschen verrühren, unterheben,
wie auch immer.
Das könnt ihr natürlich mit einer Gusseisenpfanne ruhig machen.
Da braucht ihr keine Angst haben.
Guck mal, richtig cremig die Sauce schon!
Je nachdem, was für einen Geschmack ihr habt,
könnt ihr jetzt noch ein bisschen würzen,
aber natürlich ist die Gemüsebrühe meiner Frau schon sehr, sehr gewürzt.
Also nicht übertreiben.
Guck mal, das ist richtig schön angedickt.
So. Und in der Zwischenzeit machen wir die Bavette.
Jetzt nehmen wir heißes Wasser.
Ist besser, weil dann geht’s schneller.
Das Rezept ist wirklich auf 4 Personen ausgelegt.
Nudeln, eh das Wasser richtig kochen lassen.
Und damit nichts schiefgeht… Nein [Doing]
Ich wollte die Kochblume nehmen. Tschuldigung.
Und das Wichtigste bei Nudeln ist wirklich,
sie müssen bissfest sein.
Also Nudeln, die total durchgekocht sind, mag ich wirklich null!
Richtig schön bissfest.
Und mit dem Kupfertopf geht’s natürlich extrem schnell.
[Musik]
Nudelwasser natürlich mit Deckel aufkochen lassen –
geht viel, viel schneller.
Jetzt nehmen wir die Nudeln. Das Wasser kocht jetzt schon.
Die Bavette – mache sie rein.
Und jetzt, auch ganz wichtig, erst salzen, wenn das Wasser heiß ist.
Sonst macht ihr den Topf kaputt.
[Musik]
Seht ihr: Wenn ich jetzt den Deckel draufhätte,
dann würde das überlaufen,
aber durch die Kochblume ist das kein Problem. [Doing]
Oh, ich mache den Deckel drauf.
Okay, hey! Tut mir leid! Ich weiß nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Ich bin zum ersten Mal in der Küche. So ein Mist! Das gibt’s nicht.
Bei meiner Frau funktioniert’s.
So. [Herd piept] Oh mein Gott!
So. Kleine Fehler passieren mal.
So. Die sind aber noch nicht durch. Dann geht’s weiter.
Ich habe einfach zu viel Wasser reingemacht. Das war mein Problem.
[Herd piept] Warte, jetzt muss ich alles saubermachen.
[Doing] Kurz durchschließen. Tut mir leid, ging alles in die Hose.
So, die Nudeln sind jetzt durch.
Und hier ist ganz, ganz wichtig: Nicht zu durch,
weil ich tu sie ja nachher nochmal hier in die Sauce rein.
Dann gart es auch nochmal ein bisschen nach.
Jetzt nehme ich hier… Bamm! [Doing]
Und zwar, ein Faltsieb!
Hier ganz wichtig: Die Kochblume so abtupfen.
Den Topf… und einfach ins Sieb geben.
So. Die Nudeln sind jetzt auch fertig.
Ganz wichtig, es gibt eine goldene Regel bei Italienern:
Die Sauce wartet immer auf die Nudeln.
Ganz, ganz wichtig: Sauce wartet auf die Nudeln.
Jetzt machen wir Folgendes: Jetzt tun wir hier die Sauce,
wo ich vorhin gemacht habe, ein bisschen nochmal erhitzen.
So.
Jetzt geben wir die Nudeln mit rein. Zack!
Und den Spinat, aber erst das Fleisch und das Gemüse.
[Musik]
Jetzt mache ich etwas. Es ist sehr, sehr unkonventionell,
aber ich sage euch den Grund, warum ich das mache,
und zwar nehme ich jetzt erstmal eine Schere.
Wenn ich wüsste, wo eine Schere ist.
[Doing] Ah, hier! Zack!
Und zwar, man hätte das Fleisch,
dass es nachher cooler aussieht und besser portionierbar ist,
auch in Scheiben schneiden können.
Nur wenn ich das Fleisch in Scheiben schneide,
habe ich immer Angst, dass es zu arg durch wird
und zu lederhaftig ist.
Deswegen mache ich jetzt Folgendes:
[Musik]
Ein Life Hack fürs Leben, gell?
So, jetzt machen wir Folgendes:
Machen wir das Gemüse noch mit rein. Jawoll!
So. Und Gemüse, Nudeln und jetzt noch den Spinat.
So. Sieht jetzt nach viel Spinat aus, aber der zerfällt gleich.
Einfach nochmal ein bisschen auf mittlerer Hitze.
So. Und jetzt hoffen wir einfach, dass er zerfällt.
Ansonsten war’s zu viel Spinat. Aber macht euch keine Sorgen [lacht],
der wird gleich zerfallen.
In der Zwischenzeit räumen wir auf.
[Musik]
So. Fertig!
Sieht perfekt aus.
Man kann’s jetzt je nach Belieben noch ein bisschen nachwürzen.
Perfekt. Jetzt brauche ich noch jemanden, der probiert.
Ich glaube, alle arbeiten. Deswegen hole ich mir die Sarah.
[Sarah lacht]
MURAT: Sarah, komm mal her! Jetzt probier‘ mal!
So.
SARAH: Hast du ganz alleine gemacht?
MURAT: Ja, und ich bin echt mal gespannt, wirklich!
SARAH: Ja, ich auch!
MURAT: Ich muss dir ehrlich sagen:
Ich mach das ja nach den Rezepten von meiner Frau
und ich hab das zum ersten Mal gemacht. [Lacht]
So, jetzt probiere du es mal aus.
SARAH: Nicht zu viel! Ich brauche doch auch noch was fürs Foto.
MURAT: Stimmt, du musst ja noch arbeiten. Ach so, nicht so viel.
SARAH: Ich muss es ja noch fotografieren.
MURAT: Nicht so viel, du musst ja noch fotografieren.
Übertreib doch nicht. Du bist voll gierig, weißt du das? So.
SARAH: Wie nennt sich das?
MURAT: Ich hab’s voll vergessen. Ich bin jetzt eh… Hühnchen…
Hühnchen-Nudeln mit Spinat.
SARAH: Ah!
MURAT: Ja. Und da gibt es einen ganz krassen Namen. Der nennt sich:
Chicken Florentine Pasta.
SARAH: Oh!
MURAT: Ja, das hört sich krasser an, gell?
SARAH: Ja, hört sich echt besser an.
Ich hab gehört, du hast schon viel Olivenöl drin. Soll ich wirklich noch was…
MURAT: Ich find‘ Chili… Ja, mach’s später. Ich find‘ Chili-Öl immer cool.
Aber jetzt probier’ mal!
SARAH: Okay.
MURAT: Und sei voll ehrlich, wirklich!
Aber sei ehrlich!
Weißt du, wenn es ein Fehler ist, kann ich es den Menschen sagen
und dann machen sie den Fehler nicht.
SARAH: Ich bin ehrlich! Aber ich muss erstmal essen.
MURAT: Ich probiere auch mal nur ein bisschen.
Weil ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich habe Hunger.
SARAH: Hmm!
MURAT: Wenn du es gegessen hast,
sage ich dir, was das Besondere daran ist.
SARAH: Ist da Sahne drin?
MURAT: Nein, ein bisschen Milch.
SARAH: Mir fehlt ein bisschen Pfeffer.
MURAT: Ja, ich habe es auch gerade gemerkt.
Aber das ist ja Geschmackssache.
SARAH: Ja.
MURAT: Mir fehlt aber Salz. Zack!
So.
SARAH: Ja, aber ansonsten ist gut.
MURAT: Weißt du, was du daran magst? Ich sag’s dir!
SARAH: Sag’s mir!
MURAT: Und zwar Folgendes: Du magst es,
dass die Champignons und der Spinat nicht so völlig lätschig sind.
SARAH: Ja.
MURAT: Du schmeckst noch richtig, dass es Spinat ist, weißt du?
SARAH: Für mich kann es sogar noch mehr Spinat sein.
MURAT: Ehrlich?
SARAH: Ja.
MURAT: Boah, das war schon ziemlich viel Spinat.
Und weißt du, was dir noch gefällt?
SARAH: Was gefällt mir?
MURAT: Dass die Nudeln auch nicht lätschig sind.
SARAH: Ja.
MURAT: Und die Kunst bei diesem Essen…
Die Kunst bei dem Essen ist gar nicht…
Das Essen ist voll, voll einfach. Weißt du, was die Kunst hierbei ist?
Die Nudeln… dass die noch bissfest sind [Sarah stimmt zu]
und dass das Gemüse auch richtig gegart worden ist.
SARAH: Ist das so ein One Pot?
MURAT: Nein, das habe ich nicht hingekriegt.
Und das Hühnchen ist durch [Sarah stimmt zu]
Aber nicht ledrig.
SARAH: Nicht zäh, ja! [Murat stimmt zu]
Wie mit Gemüse.
MURAT: Weil viel falsch machen kannst du nicht.
Es schmeckt einfach lecker. [Sarah stimmt zu]
Ding ist drin… Champignons sind noch drin und…
SARAH: Ich habe keinen einzigen Champignon.
MURAT: Richtig lecker, gell?
SARAH: Schmeckt sehr, sehr gut. Sehr gesund. [Murat stimmt zu]
MURAT: Tut mir leid, ich war noch am Essen. Habe ich voll vergessen.[Sarah lacht]
Auf jeden Fall macht es zu Hause nach. Ist ganz, ganz easy.
Ihr habt gemerkt, wo hier die Fallstricke sind.
Wenn ihr das nach Anleitung macht, so wie ich es gemacht habe,
kann gar nichts schiefgehen.
Hat mir auf jeden Fall Spaß gemacht.
5 Minuten haben wieder nicht gereicht. Ich laber einfach zu viel.
Deswegen macht’s gut!
Habe ich die Geschichte von Barilla erzählt?
SARAH: Die mit dem Pesto?
MURAT: Nein, die mit dem… ich erzähle dauernd Geschichten, gell?
SARAH: Ja, du hast schon viel…
MURAT: Ich kann nochmal eine Geschichte erzählen.
SARAH: Erzähl mir!
MURAT: Wusstest du, dass Nudeln gar nicht aus Italien kommen?
Nudeln sind aus China. [Sarah stimmt zu]
Die wurden dann von Marco Polo im 13. Jh.
nach Italien gebracht, [Sarah stimmt zu]
und zwar ganz genau genommen nach Napoli.
SARAH: Ah!
MURAT: Und aus Napoli kam sie dann in die ganze Welt.
SARAH: Okay.
MURAT: Und alle denken immer noch, das wären Nudeln aus Italien.
Sie sind auch China,
aber natürlich machen die Italiener die tollsten Sachen daraus.
SARAH: Ja.
MURAT: Ja. Und das ist Bavette.
Bavette ist das Gleiche wie Linguine.
SARAH: Linguine!
MURAT: Genau. Und dann gab’s 2 Hotspots:
Einmal war Napoli so ein Nudel-Hotspot und Genua.
Die haben sich dauernd gebattelt.
Die haben die Nudeln einfach noch ein bisschen verändert,
um einfach anders zu sein wie der andere.
SARAH: Ja, okay.
MURAT: Das heißt, Bavette ist ein bisschen anders.
Die sind nicht rund, aber auch nicht flach.
Keiner weiß, was sie eigentlich sind. Und…
SARAH: Was hat das jetzt mit Barilla zu tun?
MURAT: Andere Geschichte. Macht’s gut! Tschüss!
Ach so, nein! Abonniert den Kanal.
SARAH: Und die Glocke.
MURAT: Und die Glocke anklicken. Aber ist ja gar nicht mein Kanal.
SARAH: Gibt’s das auch in der App?
MURAT: Aber egal, abonniert den Kanal von meiner Frau einfach.
Genau, dann sehen wir uns mal wieder.
Und hatet mich nicht. Hatet die anderen.
Hatet irgendjemand anderen. Genau
SARAH: Ja.
MURAT: Tschüss.
SARAH: Tschüss.
MURAT: War echt lecker, gell?
SARAH: Ja, schmeckt gut!
MURAT: Musst gar nicht lügen, gell?
SARAH: Die Nudeln sind ein bisschen zu lang drin gewesen.
MURAT: Nein, finde ich nicht.
SARAH: Findest du nicht? Sie können ein bisschen…
MURAT: Nein, das ist Geschmackssache.
SARAH: … besser sein. Aber schmeckt sehr gut.
MURAT: Sind gar nicht… absolut nicht.
SARAH: Nicht? [Murat verneint]
Warte.
Deine Frau macht es ein bisschen fester.
MURAT: Echt? Dann arbeite doch mit meiner Frau!
So. Tschüss.
[Musik]